i want to show you this article i got
from the atlantic
this is a series this was an article
published august 13th it's a series on
ancient rome in the fall of the roman
republic and it's uh really really quite
interesting now this guy running for the
atlantic it's a mainstream media thing
it's a left left wing said he basically
says the trump supporters live in
fantasyland and the reactionaries
clearly doesn't like trump supporters
but here's what he says
will the trumpest party similarly
ultimately prevail once they cross the
rubicon i have been predicting for years
that something resembling a civil war
will arise and something like trump as
trumpists likely will carry the day in
the short term but a reactionary
philosophy that rejects fact in favor of
fantasy is economically retrograde and
socially repugnant to the majority of
americans can can impose its rule only
for so long
you know what's really funny about that
when you take out the fact that the
trump supporters are not the ones who
believe in fantasy but typically are the
ones who are critically thinking not all
of them they have their zealots what
he's basically saying is the trump
supporters will win but we hold again
and so and
yeah but the ins but the the military
and the cops have guns too this is this
is one thing that right doesn't seem to
understand you know i see these comments
all the time they were like how is the
left going to win a conflict when the
right of the ones are the guns i don't
know the right's the one that they're
leaving the military the officers are
resigning and quitting the police force
and leaving in the establishment shills
who are armed
but in this if you if you if you're
operating under the presumption
that trump supporters are going to win
and then say but they can't hold power
for long because you know insert
disparaging comments about trump
supporters okay well
if you look at the right if you look at
the the thought leaders on the right
they're typically critical thinkers
they're biased like daily wire is
conservative by its site but they don't
post lies
then the reality is it's the left that's
retrograde and reactionary and in favor
of fantasy they think the economy is
good right now
so so what what they're really saying is
this guy based on his assessment of
ancient rome what's happening now thinks
there will be a civil war and the trump
side will win
i wonder too like when people say civil
war do they literally mean for the
entire country or do they just mean like
in some region of it you know will be
taken over because like it would be the
entire country like we just got to claim
alaska and hawaii somehow it's just no
it's not a package sure
so
people the problem with americans is
that their view of civil war is based on
one of the most unique internal
conflicts in history the american civil
war was a union of states of different
jurisdictions aligning against each
other whereas most civil wars are
factions fighting everywhere in the
country at the same time so if you look
at the spanish civil war and see like
the different pockets that emerged of
the net the republicans versus the
communists or whatever and then they're
fighting each other and then gaining
more and more ground and eventually they
take over and i think spain went you
know military dictatorship or whatever
that's like oh okay that's how civil war
operates but americans are like there
was the mason-dixon line and then west
virginia became a state and virginia
separated and it's like
that's because each state
was basically a country right with a
sovereign state and so when the union
got shaky states seceded of their own
accord without
what other states thought and then
because of the conflict the confederacy
joined forces to defend themselves
against the union that's why they called
it the war of northern aggression was
there a big call from the citizenry to
to go to civil war the american civil
war was that all like a government and
it was a government all the governors
were just decided right not a governor
thing i think it was a government thing
the legislatures and i think regular
people didn't want it but nothing could
be done i mean first and foremost
slavery
here's the other difference between a a
modern civil war and the passive war
you can argue
and and i think this is i agree with
this that slavery was so morally
repugnant going in to stop slavery was a
cause in unto itself
meaning if we had a state right now that
was like
enslaving people i would be demanding
the federal government like we cannot
tolerate in our own country it's a
violation of all of our rights and it
must be ended immediately and so i can
certainly understand why the north was
like we're we're not going to let these
states do this first of all we they had
continually passed laws that were like
we're going to get rid of slavery and
the south was mad about it and wanted to
leave the union
war breaks out but when you have that
moral issue and i think everyone
everyone agrees like you know and it it
was a good thing to end slavery like
grief slavery was really bad well that's
the thing like name a person right now
i'm sure there are some crackpot you
know uh individuals and racists who are
like angry about it but 99.99 of
everyone agrees right it turned out
properly it was the right thing today we
do not have that moral issue our moral
issues are like i live in the mountains
of west virginia and i want to own a gun
well i'm from new york and i think you
shouldn't be allowed to have one
could you imagine
that makes no sense there's no no one's
going to invade west virginia to end the
the moral repugnance of gun ownership
and no no no one from west virginia is
going to go invade new york to stop them
they're going to be like what's going to
happen is
washington's gonna be like
we out yeah i also have this thought too
in my uh various streams of secession i
had this thought that like i think the
biggest of i2 is urban rural and that
even if a state were to succeed its
population center is probably still
going to be left-wing and still have
outsized influence even if you know
people you know in the majority of the
square mileage of it are right-wing so
and i know this will never happen but i
don't know it would make more sense to
have you know sort of city-states for
liberals and then you know everything
else for the conservatives
yeah they'd fall into seconds i think it
is true that even in west virginia the
states are are blue it's the craziest
thing people should check this out come
to west virginia go to central west we
were in central west virginia in some
small town and the bar's got the the
trans rainbow flag
and i'm like we're in central west
virginia
and i'm like i don't understand why or
even small urban centers become leftist
the internet you know yeah the internet
yeah i mean there's actually a really
interesting book by jonathan height and
he points out that conservatives and
liberals actually have different brain
structures and that we i mean we are
just fundamentally different and it
could just be naturally people with more
left leaning and progressive views tend
to concrete among other people and
weaker people who need support and want
to mooch off others and conservatives is
kind of like you know space and like
there have been polls and it's like with
conservatives would you rather have to
drive 10 minutes to get somewhere or
walk you know 10 minutes and most
liberals will say oh i'll walk to the
store and see the servers would prefer
the drive um and those traits just kind
of self-select you into that kind of
lifestyle yeah um yeah jonathan knight's
research is fascinating
liberals have only two of six moral
foundations yes care and fairness
conservatives have all six and
libertarians only have one what is it
what's theirs liberty oh that's it yeah
it's amazing the only thing yeah so
there's you can take these tests to
weigh your moral foundations
and uh
when i take the test it comes up left
liberal but it's because i have a little
bit more care and fairness and then a
slight balance across the board liberty
care and fairness for me are really
really high and i think that really
makes sense i'm like i'm left with a lot
of policy issues but i'm
i favor more liberty which means i'm
typically in opposition to the
authoritarianism and then when it comes
to the other moral foundations i do have
them more than the average liberal
but watching libertarians take the test
because some of these questions
like i can't even say what some of the
questions are
like
oh man there's there's questions about
incest yes oh yeah and so libertarians
are like
zero on these other more foundations and
liberties a hundred because they're like
i don't care what you do get the
government out and i'm like
i don't i i've got yeah cause there's
there's purity there's a thought there's
loyalty there's authority liberty care
and fairness i think are the you know so
purity is like
there's a reason for that moral
foundation because and i i was reading
about i think purity has a lot to do
with disease
that people who didn't care about like
debauchery
would be more likely to spread diseases
so you end up with
certain traditions emerging of being
clean and being you know you can see
like in religion like not even shellfish
it's like well at that time it actually
was a pretty you know brilliant
suggestion yeah and pork yeah yeah which
i've you know broken but
yeah yeah yeah well now we we've we've
gotten better at you know cleaning and
cooking and everything so it's safer but
you can see those those things still
exist but i'll add one thing to this too
you know i don't know exactly what
happened in in terms of civil war but i
can say if we have two distinct cultures
forming in this country laws cannot be
enforced period so the example i give is
that i don't if you've ever seen these
books it's like wacky laws the u.s
doesn't oh yeah there's a million of
them yeah but why don't we enforce those
laws like like you can't you can't take
showers on tuesdays and you know rhode
island yeah we just know intuitively
it's absurd and i mean at the time it
made sense
yeah so
i'm not saying rhode island literally
bans showers but there are places in the
east coast that were like you can't
shower on tuesdays why well maybe
because tuesday was the day they they
allotted to the farmers to get access to
the fresh water so they could you know
from their crops and you couldn't be
well and then there's some there's some
things where it's like you can't uh put
pies in the window sill on sunday
mornings maybe it's because sunday
mornings is when the church would come
and it would attract animals and then
there'd be people around it would cause
problems and no more putting your food
on the windowsills to cool because the
animals come and but now it's the
animals are gone
and people are going to church less and
we have you know we just don't have that
problem anymore so culturally we just
ignore that law now what happens when
you have two distinct cultures
and then you have a law in the books
which is like gums it happens a lot
actually yeah what's that law the uh
it's old that old law that they were
like are they going to invoke the
insurrection act is that what it is some
old old law
yeah about like not sending a spy
overseas or something
the logan actually the guy that the act
is actually named after lobby a foreign
government after the act was passed so
it didn't even deter him when it was
passed
yeah they tried to get michael flynn on
it it was uh and it makes no sense it's
never been used not to point my own work
but i did a book but that was a a
section of it with one gene is it what
is it isn't there an argument that mark
milley may have violated the logan act
um he was he was he was in here he was
discussing us military policy with
foreign adversaries i mean i would say
yes but it it won't matter in that it's
never you know been enforced so and
that's that's where it comes down to if
republicans
actually had power and now republicans
the wrong word lindsey graham wouldn't
do anything if conservatives trump
supporters had power hillary clinton
would be indicted
uh tons of the russiagate people all
these people who lied would be indicted
per like just across the board for all
the lies they put out they'd find
something you got that one lawyer who
lied alphabet what's his name is that
yeah yeah yeah wow i mean meanwhile
debunked that like four and a half years
ago and it's just funny like the news
cycle where i'm going oh we were right
about all that that's kind of cool
so
uh a lawyer fabricated evidence he
claimed that like this there was a
server in a trump tower that was
communicating with a russian ban called
alpha bank uh and it turned out to just
be complete [ __ ] basically
and hillary clinton was tweeting it and
john podesta was tweeting it and all
these journalists were like trump's
secret server and it was i mean the
whole the whole um michael flynn with
the logan act he was called while he was
on vacation um the people who called him
knew his knew that they were gonna
sorry he knew he was gonna be getting
called by a russian ambassador because
he's on vacation there's no way from the
event his call being intercepted so the
whole thing is getting recorded and then
you know that's what it led to his
downfall under trump and they started
like mentioning the logan act and i'm
going well why would you mention the
logan act to get to take this guy down
when it's never been invoked only if
this whole thing was planned so you
could try to find some sort of reason to
get rid of the guy look and it worked
you look at everything we talked about
already the borders so porous illegal
immigrants are going back and forth
there's no there's no border biden's
watching it crumble the economy's in
shambles the the system of of of the
separation of powers is completely gone
and we had in the past five years
fake indictments or or i mean literally
against
political uh uh a political party a
political group for the sake of power
and we don't even really have three
branches anymore because as we were
talking earlier the cdc is just creating
a lot of thin air and other agencies and
there's and it's up to us to say
actually you can't do that and when the
supreme court told biden the eviction
moratorium was illegal he went i'll do
it anyway and the supreme court could do
nothing to stop him
so you look back at the russiagate stuff
and i think a lot of people said the
country was done when that stuff came
out michael flynn goes to an informal
meeting at the white house
and he gets asked so did you talk to a
russian uh ambassador and he goes no no
and they go okay then later they come
back you lied to us that's a crime it
was actually a bit
more complicated than that so they they
bring him in for questioning
as they're questioning him they have a
transfer that was informal though like
it wasn't yeah it was like two guys it
was peter struck on someone else um so
they bring a man for questioning he
didn't know he was being investigated no
so he's bringing a routine question and
he did admit to the call he told all the
contents of the call and they as they're
questioning him have a transcript of the
call in front of them meaning they're
not asking him to get the truth of what
happened they're trying to see if he's
trying to deviate and then they report
back no there was no irregularities
and then somehow in the chamber of
command and i have no idea how it
changes to he lied about its call even
though the asians had no it's singing
and there was that document that came
out where like clapper and biden had a
meeting and they were like how can we
get this guy yeah it was the democratic
party what they did with russiagate and
what vinman did with ukraine
these people are
man i don't even i don't know the right
word uh it's sedition like i honestly
like when i first started writing spygia
i was like you know this will be
interesting but like you know i it can't
be that crazy and uh it turns out like
you know that the sort of like type of
politics you see in what uh like in a
movie is actually more real than you'd
think let's break this down yeah
donald trump is on the phone with
president of ukraine and he says
something off the cuff about like you
see this what's this thing going on
about biden and and this quid pro quo or
something why don't you guys look into
that yeah trump clearly had no idea what
he was talking about this phone call but
what happened was a viral video where
joe biden's at where was he at it was um
was it wasn't the council on foreign
relations no it was uh
i can't remember this is the one where
someone bragged that he was able to the
investigation the event he was at i
can't remember the event
but he says yeah but he bragged about it
i went to the president and said look if
you don't fire the prosecutor you're not
getting the money yeah and he said you
you don't have the authority to do that
and he goes call the president yeah well
son of a [ __ ] six hours later
prosecutors fired yeah so trump hears
about this
asks the new ukrainian president like
well look at this joe budden had not
announced any political ambitions
and then everyone said trump was going
after his political rival and we were
like but biden's not running for
president this call i think or i think
that was in september that trump had
this call and people were saying he
threatened to withhold military aid but
the military aid was actually had been
withheld since i think january or
february for other reasons so so here's
what you need to understand ian yeah
that was the council on foreign
relations on formulations where he said
it
biden admits
braggs that he said he would withhold
foreign aid in exchange for getting a
guy fired the the media said but we we
do this all the time we pressure
countries for this reason so when donald
trump says i want you to investigate
what happened with this
they called that a quid pro quo even
though trump didn't ask for anything
so here's what really happens they claim
that donald trump was abusing his power
by trying to
use ukraine to go after his political
opponents what really happened was that
joe biden
shut down whether on purpose or not an
investigation multiple many
investigations but some into barisma
where his son happened to be on the
board
micholo zlatchevsky the founder of
barisma had fled ukraine biden comes and
gets the prosecutor fired zlatchevsky
returns
trump comes back in and says i want this
investigated zlatchevsky flees again
but the media comes out and says trump
was the criminal
joe biden flew on air force two with his
son to china to negotiate a private
equity deal but trump's colluding with
russia
michael flynn
who i think was talking to sally yates
and he said she's the one who sort of
she's when he first pitched the maybe he
voted for the logan act leading me to
believe because
he said i think china is a greater
adversary than russia and then all of a
sudden she was like oh jeez oh no
he's colluding with russia trying to
downplay it the reality is i think china
according to mike pompeo has infiltrated
every level of our country in a
government that's what he said you've
got the thousand talents program where
they're actually hiring our own
professors to give away our research
back to them you've got chinese
individuals being caught carrying
infectious diseases and creating them
and
bringing them illegally through the us
and then strangely
when michael flynn
says i think china's a bigger threat all
of a sudden there's alarm bells going
off the democratic party and they seek
to then get indictments and russia gate
was fake it was years where even i was
like well this is interesting we should
absolutely look into this and then
afterwards it's over rachel maddow's on
the verge of tears
listen you didn't understand when i say
these people are evil dude oh and and
the npc default liberals who line up
behind them and and in the millions to
vote for them because they're in this
matrix this is a whole new there's a
level of depravity that can be described
in words
after the hillary uh emails came out i
was just like gob stopped gobbs smacked
it like the sydney blumenthal osprey
osprey global solutions libya contracts
like that she was pushing for her buddy
sidney and nothing you know and i was
like wow he's real but then trump won so
i was like oh maybe tierney's not oh
then what did they do to him and then
what did they do oh can i get the first
anti-war president of of people's lives
can i can i just point out that um
wouldn't it be wouldn't it
okay imagine you lived in a country
and a high-ranking
cabinet member in the executive branch
had a non-profit
that was taking in millions of dollars
from foreign governments
and the pro that profit was named after
this individual in the in in the in in
the cabin in the executive branch i mean
surely that would shock people to their
cores when say like imagine saudi arabia
was giving tens of millions of dollars
to this and we'll call it the the
blinton foundation just as you know like
while they're what's his name secretary
of state
and uh we'll call it to blinton
secretary and uh yeah you get the point
the bliton foundation and then as soon
as the uh uh
this individual doesn't win the election
very corrupt yeah very very corrupt and
that was the first time the email
scandal was the first time i saw it very
clearly very because it was very obvious
if you looked at the emails and you
looked up sidney blumenthal and you want
to look at like she was directly
instructed by obama not to work with
sydney and she was just doing it because
he was an old clinton advisor for like
30 years he's worked at the clintons
it's it's it's terrifying it doesn't
mean that it's impossible thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time